pour commencer à 4000 m jackman c'est
son nom saute d'un avion puis quelques
instants plus tard à lui ses réacteurs
et voilà personne n'a jamais voulu
croire à son idée il faut dire que ça
n'est pas banal
quatre réacteurs à l'arrière d'une
petite elle beaucoup tout essayé mais
jusqu'à présent personne n'a réussi et
ça pousse dur 160 à leur altitude de
croisière 2000 mètres toutes ces figures
sont permis
après 6 minutes de vol plus de carburant
tout s'arrête
jetman tire alors sur la poignée
d'ouverture de son parachute il grossit
commandant de bord sur airbus a
l'habitude de dire dans la vie il faut
s'amuser pas se tuer on espère que ça
sera vrai très longtemps